So now it's time we zoom out just a bit
more on Kate's family pedigree of lactose intolerance. And hopefully you
realize now we're looking at a pedigree for a recessive
trait. This is what a recessive pedigree looks like. And let's
see if we can write down a couple of things
that we definitely know from the pedigree. Remember we might switch
back and forth between using these two different types of
symbols. The thymine cytosine DNA letter alleles versus the plus minus
symbols indicating lactase persistence on the top and
lactase nonpersistence on the bottom. Now in our pedigree,
we know that everybody who is affected is
shaded in. And they must be recessive. Homozygous recessive.
Every individual that's shaded in this pedigree must
be minus minus or c c. Based on what
we've learned so far, we know that this must be true. Now let's take a look at
Kate's parents here. Kate is effective. We know she's
minus, minus. Each parent had to give her one of
their own alleles. This means one of her minuses had
to come from mom and one of her minuses had
to come from dad. But the question is what's
the other allele? And we already know the answer, mom
and dad are unaffected. If mom and dad are unaffected,
that means their other allele has to be a plus,
because if it was a minus then both mom and
dad would also be affected and you'd see them shaded
in as well. But they're not, we know they're not
affected. This information about trait has been able to inform us
about what their possible genotype is. This is what makes
categories so amazing. We know immediately what Kate's genotype must be.
We know what her parents' genotypes must be. But now,
let's look at her brother. We know her brother's not effected,
so he could be either plus plus or plus minus
and actually the problem here is all we know is that
he has one plus. He could be plus, plus right?
He could have gotten a plus from each parent or he
could have gotten a plus from one parent and a
minus from another parent. We don't know. So that's actually still
an unknown variable for us right now. It's something we
can't determine from the pedigree. This is one of our limits.
Now there's another really amazing pattern that this
pedigree reveals to us. We learned earlier, that
the trait itself of lactose intolerance, skips generations.
Kate's maternal grandfather is affected by lactose intolerance.
Her mother is not, but then Kate is.
The trait skipped a generation. But now look
at the genotypes. We know her grandfather must
be minus minus, her mother must be minus plus,
and she is also minus minus. That
minus allele traveled from here grandfather to her
mother to her. So although her mother doesn't
show the trait, one of the alleles that
contribuets to the trait that Kate has
Was passed from her grandfather to her mother
to her. So for a recessive trait like
lactose intolerance, using the information from the pedigree
that we've been discussing, which of the following items
are true. Now this can be a very tricky problem.
I do not want you to be intimidated. But I
do want you to take your time and think about
it. These are check-boxes, which means there are lots
of possible combinations here. I want you to see if
you can figure out which of these items are true
and check any and all boxes that you think apply.
Now if you get frustrated, don't worry. Go to the discussion forums. See if
you can get some other hints about how to figure this out. And if you
really think it'll be helpful go ahead and skip ahead to the solution video but
please, please try and think about this one and answer it on your own first.